you ever thought about the ethical
questions surrounding s humans we're
making a decision let's go in and let's
fight let's put ourselves in danger and
bringing a dog into that situation are
they aware of what they're being asked
to do do you think I they don't look at
it as a job they look at it as a game
that's to him he's getting paid with a
toy and he's always he just wants to
play the game so in his mind his
understanding is I'm I'm getting paid to
play games and go find bombs he doesn't
think of as a bomb and then you have to
look at the fact that where one dog goes
four to five individuals would have to
go in his place right right so I guess
that's the level that we yeah you guys
are very happy that you have these these
these dogs helping you it's a phenomenal
experience you said that he's a house
dog now is that true rose by all means
yes he Robbie's retired he is fully
retired his that the most strangest he
looks robber he looks like he doesn't
have it's all good is he what's he do
now is he in the morning when it's cool
outside he tries to find the Sun and
then in the afternoon he tries to find
the shade that's about the extent of his
daily daily chores so ya see by any
chance of a condo in Florida
if he if he does he hasn't invited me
does he use can he use any of these
skills now I mean he learned all these
amazing skills can you say like Robbie
is this milk spoiled you know is it now
is there ways in which is he still has
the capability of biting and attacking
individual but yeah but so do I yeah now
who owns him now I mean it's your days
your dog oh he's your dog yes 100% my
dog he lives at my house he plays with
my kids and he enjoys government
property no not anymore that's not right
and a majority of our dogs that that's
our goal at the end of their working
life get him home let him enjoy the rest
of their days as a house pet can he it's
yeah it's fascinating to me well I think
we have a picture of Robbie at home just
hanging out
[Music]
I think that same at a Phish concert
yeah just totally now you had mentioned
I believe that this is a program that
might be eliminated or at least severely
trimmed down not eliminated so so what's
happening is we wind down our troops in
Afghanistan that we're sort of doing the
same thing with our dog teams it's only
natural but the military has a really
bad history when it comes to our dog
programs so that you know I'm a little
bit worried then we might scale back the
capability so far that if we need them
again that we won't have them at the
ready you want the people who have the
expertise to train these dogs you you
want to definitely because if you think
about it you know their capability is of
course useful in a combat zone but it's
it's also useful here and you know I
think that these dogs could easily be
sort of transitioned into you know
homeland security right thank you
well he's a beautiful he's a beautiful
dog and just this has been fascinating
it was really cool having you all on the
show thanks so much for being here
Rebecca Franko Jeff surgery fairly her
taffy and Robbie and we'll take a break
we come back post brothers are here
[Music]
you